l'espace récréatif ne peut plus se
résumer à un grand terrain de foot
bitumée avec les garçons qui jouent au
milieu et les filles qui jouent autour
cette époque est révolue c'est avec ces
mots solennels que la maire ps de rennes
nathalie appéré a ouvert la nouvelle
année scolaire dans la capitale bretonne
après trappe ou grenoble rennes s'engage
à lutter contre les stéréotypes de genre
pour les initiateurs du concept tout est
simple les garçons jouent au foot au
delà pour les filles à la corde à sauter
autour et ça c'est pas bien c'est
sexiste donc il faut y remédier la cour
ne doit plus être perçu comme un espace
où les garçons se défoule et les filles
discutent entre elles sur un banc elle
doit au contraire être un lieu de
rencontre où ils apprennent à vivre
ensemble
c'est d'autant plus important que les
relations se tendent souvent à
l'adolescence entre les filles et les
garçons
le problème ce sont les raccourcis prix
ce ton assuré de grands seigneurs cache
en réalité une réduction banale des
enfants à leurs conditions
tous les garçons jouent pas au foot
toutes les filles ne jouent pas à la
poupée et il arrive quotidiennement que
filles et garçons jouent ensemble au
foot au volet à la marelle et j'en passe
les relations qui se tendent entre les
filles et les garçons à l'adolescence en
fait c'est plutôt le contraire
les ados se mettent à sortir ensemble et
à s'intéresser les uns aux autres en
voulant lutter contre les stéréotypes de
genre ce qui se passe ici en fait c'est
que la municipalité ancré au contraire
et oui le quotidien 20 minutes très
enthousiaste explique dans son article
que des espaces végétalisés ont
également été plantés et dépend installé
à moyen pour la ville de lutter contre
les effets du réchauffement climatique
en créant des îlots de fraîcheur mais
aussi de faire évoluer les usages dans
la cour en offrant aux élèves des
espaces plus propice à la détente ou à
l'exploration
ça ne serait pas un peu capilotracté
tiré par les cheveux
regardez les photos des îlots de
fraîcheur ouais il ya deux armées quatre
rocher c'est pas en plantant deux arbres
et en mettant deux trois rochers dans la
cour on lutte efficacement contre le
réchauffement climatique et concret des
îlots de fraîcheur à rennes
on parle pas d'un oasis dans le désert
du qatar ni vos explorations où il ya
des bouts de bois par terre de plus un
rocher c'est glissant c'est saillants il
pleut l'enfant tombe boom ces points de
suture
bravo indiana jones loin de moi l'idée
de vouloir casser l'ambiance rénover une
cour d'école c'est très bien ils ont mis
un nouveau toboggan des petits chemins
c'est très bien mais le ton prix est
complètement exagéré on dirait qu'ils
ont mis un parc éolien dans la cour
pourquoi en faire des tonnes pourquoi
tout mélanger lutter contre les
stéréotypes de genre est le
réchauffement climatique
et pourquoi pas contre le fascisme tant
que vous y êtes continuez de rénover les
écoles c'est nécessaire mais arrêtez de
vous octroyer des mérites surdimensionné